good morning believe nation today's
message is do as you say
over to you Wang Jianlin just a woman
quit that hike on a shovel to [ __ ] in
caves again woman the Pope answers so
you don't wind up alone come chill dad
don't have of course I'm I don't know
Tony sirs what don't I miss it when you
hear that so young and she eat enemy
take that your woman you Twitter
drinking the meat ha ha this is probably
one of the most important messages that
you can have as an entrepreneur because
your word should be your bond right what
you say you're going to do should be
what you actually do right you should
show up on time you should deliver the
product or service that you promised
that you would deliver because if you
don't the gravitation starts to suffer
and people aren't going to want to hire
you back and spread the word you need
the word of mouth marketing to happen
for your business to take off and that
only happens when your clients are happy
with what you're doing because you did
what you said you would do
I recently connected with an
entrepreneur friend of mine who's having
a hard time getting the respect of his
staff and people on his team and I told
them it's because you don't do what you
say you're gonna do
it's a big challenge for him you know he
has the best of intentions he's not a
liar he's not a cheat he just forgets
stuff you know he's the type A
personality always chattering always
talking a great people person but he
forgets stuff and he forgets what he's
supposed to do forgets what he said he
did and then he doesn't follow through
and so his team doesn't respect him as
much anymore
and they often have to cover for him and
take on his projects because they don't
think he's gonna actually get around to
doing them and so that's a problem you
need to have the respect of your team
when you need to do what you say you're
gonna do
I can totally empathize because I don't
have a great memory mice
that's why I always carry around my iPad
right
I always carry around my iPad at any
time a new idea comes or any time I
promise that I'm gonna do something for
somebody I send a note to myself I email
myself where I put it into Evernote
because I'm worried that I'm gonna
forget it and I don't want to let them
down I want to make sure I'm always
doing what I say I'm going to do so I'm
compensating for my weakness by letting
technology do some of the work for me so
the question of the day today is I'm
curious when you're dealing with
suppliers how important is it that they
do what they say they're gonna do for
you if you have a story to share to
leave it in the comments below I'm
really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events vessel how important
is it that you do what you say you're
gonna do or that they do what they're
gonna or that they say not hold a count
but then start that over